Get ready with me
as I make party food for my 3 year old's birthday party.
As someone who avoid seed oils,
refined sugars, artificial flavors,
and food dyes at all cost,
I started in the morning by preparing my sourdough pizza
by freshly milling primitive wheat into whole grain flour
and then making with my sourdough starter,
which I hadn't fed in over 24 hours.
I covered my dough with compostable cling wrap
and let that ferment all day.
Next, I started making a birthday cake.
First, I whipped up the cake battery process that takes only 30 minutes
using eggs from my hands. While the rounds baked,
I whipped up some homemade buttercream icing
a 15 minute process
using a touch of spirulina to naturally dye it for my little boy.
Then I got to making a fish ceviche which included chopped tomatoes,
those red onions, cilantro,
mango, salt and pepper,
and lots of citrus juice. I let that marinate in the fridge
and continued on by making a homemade ranch dip for carrot
crudite taste. This dip is so good and easy to make.
I just mixed together some dried spices,
salt and pepper, and then move that to the fridge.
Now it's time to shape the sourdough into pizza balls
so this can rise a bit. Before making pizza.
I make some pickled red onions by heating some vinegar,
water, salt,
coconut sugar, and a bay leaf and then dress the big salad.
I mix it With a champagne vinaigrette
just as the party's about to start.
Then I replayed the CBJ and finish it with a vinegar concoction
from the pickled onions and a bunch of avocado pieces.
I start pumping out fresh to order pizza for the guests,
which cook on the outdoor grill for a perfectly crispy thin crust.
And I forgot to video my homemade vanilla ice cream,
but this was used to accompany the birthday cake,
the star of the evening.